[Applause]
[Music]
guitar is the wealthiest country on the
planet their citizens enjoy a higher GDP
per capita than the Swiss or indeed any
of the Nationals from any of the other
oil-rich monarchies but today we are not
going to talk about this it's actually
most important fact of this country is
not their wealth nor their absolute
monarchy or their ties with radical
terrorist groups the owners any doubt
what made this country famous can be
summarized in just two words and those
words are al-jazeera it is the most
influential TV network in the Arab world
and one of the most important news
networks on the entire planet at the
beginning of the 1990s the royal family
that ruled guitar with an iron fist the
Al Thani house had a dream they wanted
to turn their nation into the hegemonic
leader in the region but the question
was how could they achieve this goal I
mean we're talking about a tiny country
with a smaller population than the City
of Chicago
of course they couldn't rival Saudi
Arabia in the military field and Sharia
law made it impossible to be a financial
powerhouse further their geographical
position was nothing special either
there was only one possible strategy and
that was the idea of so-called soft
power in other words the influence
diplomacy and well propaganda since then
Qatar has invested more than any other
country in improving their image to
outsiders by doing things like hosting
the soccer World Cup in 2022 a Formula
One race and even directly sponsoring
soccer team
but among all these projects the most
successful and famous of them all has to
be their TV network al-jazeera they are
the market leader in terms of audience
in the entire Arab world in fact their
market share surpasses all of their
rivals put together and this is all
despite the fact that the channel is
banned in most countries
[Music]
al Jazeera has led to the overthrow of
government in several nations they have
amplified the effects of the Arab Spring
and they've even become the unofficial
loudspeaker for some terrorist groups
since the attacks of September the 11th
aljazeera has become in many ways the
only source of information for
understanding what is going on in some
parts of the world even CNN buys their
footage in other words they are a
respected media institution well then
again you might wonder well different al
Jazeera just a state propaganda channel
I mean to what extent should we really
trust their information and importantly
what's their ideology well today we are
going to answer all of these questions
but before we do that let's take a look
at some history the importance of being
unique in 1995 the BBC closed their Arab
Channel because the Saudi government
wanted to interfere in their editorial
process 150 journalists got fired all of
them Arab journalists who were trained
at one of the most prestigious media
organizations in the world these people
have a deep knowledge of Muslim culture
but at the same time they couldn't meet
the high standards of Western media this
is where the Emir of Qatar is at I'm
Hamad al-thani comes in
[Music]
I'll Tommy had just come to power and
had a clear vision for his country he
wanted it to become the leader of the
Islamic world in order to achieve that
those 150 unemployed journalists were
given an opportunity as soon as they
lost their jobs Qatar offered them brand
new ones now what was their mission
well that was to create a brand new news
network an Arab seeking media outlet
that would meet the quality of Western
media that's any cost
katella's government's gave them a one
hundred and forty seven million dollar
loan and with that this team of 150
journalists could buy state-of-the-art
studios as correspondents in many
countries and broadcast through a
satellite every little detail was taken
care of for example to design their logo
the Emir made a public contest finally
this one the one that you see on the
screen now was the winner and as you can
see it reads al Jazeera in Arabic
[Music]
finally in 1996 al-jazeera that means
the island in arabic started
broadcasting to the arab world in very
little time at all they surpassed the
rest of their rivals
think about it I mean back in the day
Arab TV was extremely boring in this
part of the world freedom of the
expression doesn't really exist and
therefore TV news just offered official
announcements al-jazeera was different
they had no problem with criticizing
various politicians and royal families
they showed corruption scandals and they
even interviewed political dissidents
all of this was done in a dynamic style
that had never been seen on Arabic
television before nevertheless the real
turning point for Al Jazeera was 9/11
Osama bin Laden used this TV network to
broadcast his claims of a terrorist
attack all of a sudden the name al
Jazeera was being said on TV news around
the world but not only that a month
after the terrorist attack the American
government had declared war on
Afghanistan back then all the big media
corporations like CNN or CNBC had
correspondents in Tokyo London or Berlin
but no one at source
Kabul would be that newsworthy sans
world death he did have an office in the
Afghan capital yep that would be al
Jazeera since they were a channel
targeted to the Muslim world they had
correspondents in all of the Muslim
countries suddenly al Jazeera footage
was appearing on televisions all around
the world this is why in 2004 the Emir
of Qatar realized that what he had not
only with the powerful tool to reach the
Arab world that indeed the world at
large and this is how English al Jazeera
was born and it was ready to broadcast
into the most competitive media market
in the world the United States of
America
[Music]
since then al Jazeera has become the TV
news that talks about countries that
never appear on American TV news want to
know about Africa's well tune and Al
Jazeera what about the Middle East again
go to Al Jazeera Central Asia we are
beginning to get the picture
let's do wait a minute because things
are not quite as great as they seem to
be don't forget we are talking about a
TV network that is being paid for by a
government in order to instruments of a
country starving the sounds of it like
it might be propaganda well let's dive a
little bit deeper
Islam's enfant toid as we said before
al-jazeera was the first Arab TV network
that openly criticized the governments
of other countries so we started the
revolution back in 2011 rather
unsurprisingly this was not always
welcomed especially given that most of
these other countries are dictatorships
so in 2011 uprising in Tunisia started
out and the dictator of this nation
abandoned it all of these facts could
have had little to no impact abroad the
al-jazeera
had a deep coverage of this uprising so
that it could be seen in other countries
since it was a satellite station their
signal was arriving to feds all across
North Africa and the Arabian Peninsula
[Music]
this is how the inhabitants of other
countries next to Tunisia like Egypt saw
their neighbors protesting and thought
wait a minute we've also got a dictator
could we do something just like that and
of course nearly every person in
opposition whomever had a news show that
they could now watch and of course this
was not something that whens over
brilliantly wins those dictators of zero
shut down in Egypt as Mubarak fights for
control of airwaves
but well what exactly is the problem
here well censoring a satellite TV
station is harder than it seems of
course you can forbid it if you want but
if someone wants to access the station
and they have a satellite dish then
technically it's possible if you are
having problems receiving any al-jazeera
channels this guide will take you
through the process of tuning your
satellite receiver so in a matter of
months all of these Arab citizens were
seeing their neighboring countries
overthrowing their dictators and this
explains the impasse the Arab Spring
phenomenon but wait a minute again
because not everything is perfect of
course now al-jazeera helps to finish
off a lot of dictatorships but the truth
is the people they promoted on their
network were not really any more
democratic for years the Muslim
Brotherhood spiritual leader was given
his own television show on al-jazeera
[Music]
even - the Islamic state was portrayed
by Al Jazeera and adjustement opposition
Force to al-assad in Syria and even as a
group of moderate rebels the same
happens with other Sunni radical
terrorists like Al Qaeda and now you
might be wondering is al-jazeera and
networks that stands for radicalism and
against the West well the truth is
they've also been accused of just the
opposite
just ask the Emir and Bahrain and two
governments
this sort of information Nabil al hammer
told journalists that Al Jazeera's
correspondence had been banned from
Bahrain Al Hamra claimed that the
station was a medium for quote Zionist
infiltration of the Gulf region
[Music]
surprise well for many al Jazeera is
Zionist Western propaganda while for
others it's the TV station of the
radicals in fact the only common ground
for al Jazeera when it comes to ideology
is the interests of the ones who
financed them the royal house of Al
Thani who by the way don't support
freedom of speech in their own country
WikiLeaks cables claim al Jazeera
changed coverage to soup Qatari foreign
policies nevertheless this doesn't mean
they cannot show the dark side of Qatar
in fact despite being paid for by the
royal house al Jazeera is more
independent than many other state
sponsored news networks
for instance what you see on the screen
here are extracts from a talk show about
the Emir slave-like working conditions
suffered by immigrants who work in Qatar
as construction workers in this show
foreign trade unionists were invited and
had the chance to openly criticize the
Al Thani family and their policies in
other words Al Jazeera's directors are
smart enough to limit their propaganda
and not lose their audience of course
they have an ideology and a lot of
interest to meet but they are all aware
that in today's world you cannot silence
the reality of what's happening because
if you don't tell us others are going to
tell it for you
[Music]
at the end of the day al-jazeera is
forbidden in almost all countries in the
region including Saudi Arabia
nonetheless they are still the most
influential and most watched TV network
everyone knows who pays for them but at
the same time that they are the only
source for many news topics in fact the
al-jazeera model has lots of caveats in
2003 the Saudis founded their own
channel al Aurelia further the American
government has their own Arabic speaking
Network called a Haram
[Music]
what about Iranian TV his fancy V is a
spanish-speaking networks paid for by
the Iranian government in order to
influence the Hispanic world they also
have an english-speaking channel called
Press TV in 2005 Russia launched Russia
today also known as RT in while
al-jazeera keeps exploring new
possibilities their latest creation is a
plus J a Facebook page where they share
viral news
[Music]
and now our question goes to you and
that would be do you think you're to
stop watching al-jazeera because you
think it's propaganda or will you keep
enjoying their shows well maybe adding a
pinch of salt you can leave me your
answer in the comment section below I'd
love to hear it and also talking about
propaganda we've got another video where
we talk about why Putin is so popular
among Russians if you want to watch that
please do click on that link and also do
not forget to visit our friends from
reconsider mediacom who provided the
voice in this video that isn't mine also
if you like this video please do give it
a thumbs up and don't forget that we
publish brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so just hit that
subscribe button do not miss any post
and as always I'll see you in the next
video and if you want to learn more
about politics and here even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider Media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]